une fois n'est pas coutume je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui d'un homme politique
qui a dit quelque chose de plutôt vrai
enfin ce qu'il a dit interroge sur
l'adéquation entre le droit et
l'application du droit
le garde des sceaux eric dupond-moretti
puisque c'est de lui dont il s'agit a
réagi à une accusation de laxisme de
l'opposition en matière de protection
des femmes victimes de violences
conjugales
cela faisait suite au meurtre de cette
femme à mérignac brûlée vive par son
mari le ministre de la justice a déclaré
à l'assemblée nationale que son
gouvernement en avait fait bien plus que
les gouvernements précédents en matière
de protection face aux violences
conjugales
si on regarde du strict point de vue du
droit il a tort car parmi les mesures
qu'il cite l'ordonance d'éloignement du
conjoint violent a été mise en place en
2004 sous la présidence de jacques
chirac le bracelet anti rapprochement en
2010 par nicolas sarkozy et le téléphone
grave danger lui a été mise en place par
françois hollande en 2014
mais du point de vue de l'application de
ces mesures il a plutôt raison tant ces
dispositifs ont manqué de moyens ou
était mal calibré par les gouvernements
précédents
le gouvernement actuel a
considérablement renforcé ses outils le
bracelet peut être désormais imposé
avant la condamnation du conjoint
violent
le téléphone peut être fourni à une
personne en danger sans attendre une
mesure d'éloignement du conjoint
quant à l'éloignement du conjoint
justement il doit être décidée plus
rapidement alors qu'est ce que cette
affaire nous dit de notre droit d'une
part que toute nouvelle mesure est
rarement parfaite il faut du temps pour
voir ses effets pour éventuellement
l'adapter
mais aussi et surtout adopter une mesure
sérieuse et efficace ça prend du temps
ce que les citoyens qui veulent une
réponse rapide ont souvent du mal à
admettre et ça réclame des moyens ce que
le politique à lui du mal à prévoir